a lack of curiosity just might kill this
cat two of the producers of the upcoming
film adaptation of the venerable
Broadway play cats have finally surfaced
to comment on the massive backlash to
the trailers nightmarish visual
aesthetic Erik Felner and Tim Bevan are
the heads of Universal Pictures
partnering production company working
title and in a recent conversation with
Variety the pair let the cat out of the
bag regarding reactions to the spot and
their hope that the flick will find its
audience among true fans of the play
founder said what does one say the
reality is that 100 million people are
more saw the trailer and yes there were
some people that didn't like it and as
is the world we live in those who didn't
like it were the most vociferous Beavan
then jumped in to opined that those who
loved stage productions of cats which
typically future actors wearing makeup
that does not make them look like
terrifying monstrosity 'he's totally got
what the filmmakers were going for and
also that those who were turned off by
the movie spot must have been expecting
to see real actual cat singing and
dancing or maybe a cartoon he asserted
the viewers who criticized the trailer
were probably people who didn't know
cats and the fact is they were either
anticipating something animated or
something that was on four legs among
people who know cats the reaction was
pretty solid
yikes those are a couple of dubious
assumptions fella you know how foolish
you sound right now it is true that
there were comments from just such users
scattered about the Twitterverse
comments along the lines of its cats
what did you expect but they were
severely outnumbered by remarks
expressing abject horror at the spot and
wondering how on earth the filmmakers
could have failed to notice that they
were fielding a picture that didn't so
much invoke the whimsy and emotion of
the play as it did Cronenberg in body
horror now it's worth noting that the
producers claimed that the visuals
presented in the trailer were not
exactly finished and that numerous small
tweaks have been applied since the spot
was released back in July we submit
however that it's going to take a heck
of a lot more than subtle changes to
halt viewers up out of the uncanny
valley and get their butts in the seats
for cats you could say that such a
prospect would take a little bit of meow
check the casual observer could be
forgiven for thinking that we're
wringing a few too many alarm bells here
after all cats has a pretty sterling
pedigree according to play bill it's the
10th highest-grossing Broadway musical
of all time which is certainly nothing
to sneeze at the movie adaptation it
must also be said boasts a staggering
amount of talent it stars Taylor Swift
one of the most bankable celebrities of
any stripe on the planet Idris Elba one
of the most charismatic and beloved
actors alive Sir Ian McKellen the
definition of a veteran actor and a
consummate pro and Dame Judi Dench whose
title alone should tell you all you need
to know about just how well-regarded she
is the flick was co-written by Lee Hall
who penned the excellent Elton John
biopic Rocket Man and directed by Tom
Hooper who fielded the well-regarded and
financially successful 2012 Broadway
adaptation lame as a rob and who won the
Academy Award for Best Director for The
King's Speech on paper all of the
ingredients for success are there but
movies aren't made on paper and cats
represents a perfect storm of baffling
miscalculations which seemed destined to
ensure that its inevitable failure will
be noteworthy it will be legendary
first consider that cats story while
appropriate for a flashy Broadway
production doesn't translate very well
to film don't take our word for it it's
been attempted once already with a 1998
direct-to-video feature which was a
highly faithful adaptation of the stage
production and which currently sits at
20% on review aggregator Rotten Tomatoes
but come on we can all agree that even
the Broadway version is pretty out there
we just do some poppers and say whatever
comes to mind
Jellicle griddle ball MUNGO JERRY jimmy
McCracken's
second while the Broadway production
certainly has its fans it's not at all
clear that their numbers are substantial
enough to spell success for a 100
million dollar picture which considering
its holiday release frame is sure to
have a pretty massive advertising budget
third oh those horrifying visuals
even if swift Elba and company Turin
performances for the ages your picture
to paraphrase the late great Roger Ebert
is in deep trouble if the audience
doesn't even enjoy the primary act of
looking at it fourth and perhaps even
more importantly the movie is being
released on December 20th the same date
as a tiny little picture which you may
have heard of by the name of Star Wars
the rise of Skywalker II
then being released in the same month as
the final film of the Skywalker Saga
would have spell trouble for a movie
like cats that Universal chose to
release it on the same day it's nothing
short of lunacy we feel safe in
predicting right now that cats won't
just be one of the biggest flops of 2019
it will be one of the biggest flops of
this swiftly weaning decade and there's
nothing that the flicks producers stars
or anyone else can do to mitigate the
disaster to come tell it lies the
picture might have the pick of the
litter
but it's nine lives might be up before
they even start okay yeah we'll see
ourselves out check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]